[موسيقى]
القرود
تتغذى بالتأكيد من مشاعرك
التي يعرفونها عندما تشعر بالإحباط أو
عندما تشعر بالضحك ،
إنها نوع من الأسطورة الحضرية أن
الناس هناك يدربون القرود لمساعدة
الأشخاص ذوي الإعاقة
ولكن هذا يحدث
حقًا لقد حصلت على قردتي  casey لمدة 10 سنوات
في 2005 كنت في حادث سيارة ، لقد
استمتعت بـ
c1c2 الحبل الشوكي مع
إصابة في الدماغ لم أستطع تحريك
أي شيء على الإطلاق لم أستطع التحدث
كما تعلم ، لقد قطعت شوطًا طويلاً وهدفنا
هو التدريب  ووضع
قرود الكابوتشين مع أشخاص يعانون من
إعاقات حركية ،
بدأ البرنامج بالفعل
كتجربة للقول إنه
يمكننا تدريب كلب لمساعدة شخص يعاني من
إعاقة بصرية ، ربما يمكننا
تدريب أحد الرئيسيات ليكون أيدي
شخص لديه نخاع شوكي
نحن نوفر الإصابة للقرود دون أي تكلفة
لمتلقينا ، حيث تولد جميع القرود في
برنامجنا عادةً ما يقضي القرد
حوالي ثلاث إلى خمس سنوات في
مهام التعلم في كلية القرود سواء كان ذلك يجلب
هاتفًا  ه أو التحكم عن بعد بعيدًا عن الأرض
لمساعدة شخص ما في الحصول على شيء يشربه
حتى شيء
معقد مثل تقليب صفحات
كتاب ، تعمل القرود حقًا كأيدي
وتعطيهم هذا المستوى من الاستقلال
الذي يمكنك تخيله عند تعرضه
لإصابة في الحبل الشوكي وكل ذلك  فجأة يكون لديك
قرد يجلس على
كتفك ويمكنك أخيرًا
أن تشعر بهذه اللمسة للحصول على هذا القرد ،
فهناك تجربة ترابط لا تصدق
عندما لم أستطع تحريك الكيسي كثيرًا
بالنسبة لي
الآن ، هناك الكثير من
الدعم العاطفي إنه كثير  من
الرفقة
كيسي هو جزء من عائلتي ، فأنت تعلم أن
هذا حيوان يبلغ وزنه خمسة أرطال وهو
مفيد للغاية
ويجلب الفرح لحياتي
[الموسيقى]
أنت